listen to me Kanta till I get what I'm
owed a dragon doesn't get to kill you
you don't get to kill you only I get to
kill you
hey everybody this is gonna be my new
season 8 Q&A just careful for spoilers
for everything that's happened so far
there were a lot of questions based on
big twists in the book that I don't
necessarily think that I'll pay out just
based on the number of episodes that we
have so I tried to figure that in when
talking about new big groups like golden
company or the stuff that's gonna be
happening up at Winterfell once Jamie
gets up there it if you are finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get everything we'll be doing bonus
videos every week until season 8 gets
here they'll be giveaway stuff at the
end of the video - but but here we go
Anna asks do you think that Jaime could
become a personal guard - brand if he
needs to travel to find Howland Reed
I read the Howland Reed maybe a green
seer wondering if he and bran could
visit the Isle of faces so the Isle of
faces is actually a really interesting
place that they might visit if the army
of the Dead pushes them south Jamie and
bran probably won't quite be the same
thing as Jon and Daenerys the way that
he pledged his loyalty to her and you
always see them show up together if
anyone's gonna be helping brain get
around it'll probably be Samwell because
they'll be in constant communication
about really important things
remember only six episodes so there's
gonna be a lot of exposition if you
thought that they use brand purely for
exposition this season then it's
probably gonna be even worse in season
eight but as for Howland Reed there been
a lot of Howland Reed theories but
people are pretty sure that we're not
gonna see mirror Reed ever again and if
we don't see Meera then that means we
probably won't see how and Reed I think
I also mentioned it during my golden
company video a couple days ago but I'm
just not expecting too many really big
characters to be introduced for the
first time this late in the game next
one Matt asks will we get to see Jamie
1v1 anyone I'm curious to see his
fighting skills well actually if you
remember episode 4 bran basically told
him to get out of Dodge when the
Dothraki started to ride in because he's
not as good of a fighter anymore Jamie's
still a good fighter it's just that he's
nowhere close to being as good as he was
when he still had his right hand so if
bran wasn't optimistic about Jamie's
chances against the Dothraki horde that
I don't think that we'll see him fight
too many people one-on-one but he could
be a great teacher to someone else so
that's more of his role now more of a
support role more of an advisor he's
been through so many battles he has
so much insight that he could give these
younger characters that's really what
you've started to see the younger
characters have come to the forefront
they're the ones that seem to me making
all the decisions now but you need those
Jaime Tyrion Varys characters to give
them all the information they need so
that they can make good decisions not
that they will actually act on that I
think there's gonna be a lot of bad
decisions made during season eight but I
know there's a lot of people that really
want Jamie to be azor Ahai I'll do a
separate video about that because
there's like a couple requirements that
have to be met and it just depends on
what you think the ultimate end game for
his character is next one Matassa asks
what is the chance the golden company is
already in contact with Daenerys well I
don't think it's a good chance I know a
lot of people are expecting some big
twist like oh we've been talking then
this whole time I don't think it's gonna
be like that the show is so addicted to
surprises they could have some crazy
plot where Varys has been working on
this this whole time and we haven't seen
those moments but for the time being I'm
just taking it at face value Cersei has
been in contact with them through Qyburn
they're coming to support her that's all
the information that they have at the
moment
next question Miss Piggy asks Cersei is
losing it what does she want to get back
so you're asking about the golden
company giving her things that she wants
to get back I think she's talking about
Tyrion there's a number of different
ways to take her statement she could be
talking about the realm like things that
belong to me like she feels the realm
belongs to her as Queen but I think it
was a more sinister line and she was
talking about Tyrion and she wants to
put him in the dungeon the same way that
she got the sand snakes back and put
them in the dungeon Cersei probably
feels like everything belongs to her and
now that she's lost Jaime you can add
him to that list too I wouldn't be
surprised if she tried to get the golden
company to bring him back against his
will not that I think that that'll
actually end up happening next one
Tiffany asks when you do the Blackfyre
video could you make it a Targaryen
bastard video and include the Baratheon
's I find it annoying that the show
never really touches on the fact that
Baratheon czar closely related to the
Targaryens through various ways this is
actually a really interesting thing part
of the reason why people were so ready
to support Robert's rebellion and put
him on the throne is because he actually
has Targaryen blood in him right at the
end of Robert's rebellion there was a
big question about who would ascent to
the throne and even though Robert was a
big figure during the rebellion they
call it Robert
rebellion he was this great battle
commander they wouldn't have supported
his claim for the throne
had he not descended from the Targaryens
himself so Oris Baratheon the originator
of the Baratheon family was a bastard
half-brother of Aegon the conquerer so
that's where the Baratheon get their
Targaryen blood from but in the way that
Nobles intermarry across the years it's
been hundreds of years since Aegon was
alive there have been many many extended
family members in the Targaryen
bloodline that have since gone on to
marry other people around the Kingdom so
there are people all over the place that
have a little bit of Targaryen blood in
them and Robert just happened to be one
of them and because of his blood he had
a very minor claim to the throne but
obviously not as strong as Jon Snow's
claim being the direct son of Rhaegar
Targaryen next one Ricardo asks is the
diary enough to prove John's identity no
I think it's actually the diary in
concert with what bran says John
automatically trust everything brand
says there's a big question about how
they're gonna prove this how big of a
deal is the rest of the realm gonna make
about Jon Snow's heritage I really don't
think it's gonna be that big of a deal
because one I think that he's gonna be
one of the characters to die at the end
of the story so it's not like he's
actually going to be competing for the
throne with anyone and he doesn't even
want the throne himself
based on comments that Isaac Hempstead
write the actor that plays bran has said
it'll really only matter to Jon Snow in
Daenerys like does Daenerys believe that
he's part Targaryen or even Tyrion for
that matter Daenerys is closest
inner-circle like oh this is just
terrible for everyone let's just get
them apart if you remember when brand
sent the raven to john while he was a
Dragonstone and said the night king was
coming john automatically believed it at
the drop of a hat
so if bran then came and said John the
truth is is that you've never been a
bastard your name is Aegon Targaryen he
would probably believe him outright and
then Sam well it just like comes around
the corner with the diary and tells him
about the annulment than the marriage
that would be the slap in the face that
would wake him out of his funk okay I'm
really a Targaryen how am I gonna deal
with that and then you pick up in the
next episode with him and Daenerys just
being really awkward with each other but
if you're talking about proving it to
people like yawn Royce the other really
important lords that are supporting
Daenerys
Jon Snow I don't think it's gonna be
that big of a deal I think they'll just
be shocked by it they might be in
disbelief but by the time it would
actually matter like after the night
king has been defeated I don't think
it'll be an issue because I think that
Jon Snow will be dead next one acapella
asks it only occurred to me as I watched
this video that it could actually be Jon
Snow
Aegon Targaryen who ends up being the
valonqar well the problem with that is
that Jon Snow isn't the younger one
younger sibling of anyone because he's
the only child of Rhaegar and Lyanna I
will do a new valonqar video just based
on the way things have changed so far
there's still only a couple of
characters that I think could fulfill
that role one is Jaime Lannister - Arya
Stark
the Hound in then Circe's new baby
because of the way the show has sort of
avoided the book version of that I think
it's gonna be a more metaphorical the
way that it is fulfilled
next one Charles asks here's the theory
for you someone in the golden company is
going to come to Westeros with black
fire the sword of Aegon the conquerer on
learning of John's parentage will switch
sides and make sure that John gets the
heirloom back in the family as Jorah
will also get Longclaw
back into his family that would be very
cool but I actually don't think they're
gonna do black fire in the TV show and
Longclaw will just be John's sword
through the end of the story the thing
that really shows this up is when John
tried to give it to Jorah during the
season and Jorah gave him that big
speech about the sword serving him and
his future children so obviously that's
a bit of a hat tip to John having
children in the idea that the sword will
always be a part of his family so I
think that if there's going to be any
kind of black fire sword on the TV show
it's Longclaw and he already has it
right now next one David asks Faris has
been unusually quiet for most of season
7 I'm assuming this is what he's been up
to so you're actually talking about
Varys back dealing with the golden
company to betray Cersei I don't think
that that's exactly what's happening but
it's always possible the real reason I
think that we haven't seen as much Varys
is the same reason why we haven't seen
as much Littlefinger is because the way
they play the game of Thrones isn't as
big of a deal now Jon Snow is all about
big honesty there's not as much backroom
dealing as you saw in the first season
it's just the idea of getting everyone
together to fight the night King and
it's a much simpler story than what you
saw before but you can kind of see how
the old ideas are going away Daenerys is
all about breaking the wheel there's
this new way of life she's trying to
make things better for everyone a world
where people don't play the game of
Thrones in that way not that I think
that that'll actually end up happening
no matter what you do there will always
be people like Varys and Littlefinger
around but because there's only six
episodes and because it's all about the
war for the dawn I don't think we're
gonna see too much Game of Thrones Inge
happening on the TV show so the
characters that spend most of their time
doing stuff like that just aren't as
important anymore
next one Chris asks what do you think of
the idea of Dario coming back with the
golden company in a brown Ben plum role
I think it's totally possible but I have
to do like a quick explainer for who
that character is the character is
really like a self sword that switches
sides so on that level I do think that
Daario could try to help out team
Daenerys and I do think that he'll come
back even if it's only for a little bit
of band service but the character in the
books also traces his lineage back to
the Targaryens through a distant
relative I don't think that Daario has
any family connections to the Targaryen
so we don't literally think they're
gonna bring any plum on the TV show but
if you are only talking about him trying
to trick Cersei then I totally think
that's a possibility but thank you so
much for sending questions these are
always a ton of fun to do what I might
do next for my bonus video later this
week is actual death predictions I've
gotten so many questions about that
there are a couple characters that I'm a
little fluid on but there are a few that
I'm definitely sure will wind up dying
so we can talk about them in a couple
days but leave all your requests for
bonus videos in the comments below
there's still a couple characters that I
need to get through but congratulations
to the latest giveaway winner sarna's
Hammadi please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there'll be a new round
the next time I post Game of Thrones
while you wait for everything you can
click here for that golden company video
and you can click here for all my other
season 8 videos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you